oh
good to see you Mr President
yeah
next time I hope we get to do it face to
face like we used to when we travel
through China
although it's not as good as a
face-to-face meeting I'm very happy to
see my old friend
and Chinese spies and I'm Dave Rubin
this is the Reuben report it's February
6 2023 we are live streaming on Rumble
YouTube and locals if you have not
joined us for the post game shows
they're very very exciting very exciting
extremely exciting people
reubenreport.locals.com uh do join us
over there a couple things to get off my
chest at the beginning of the show today
first off we had an incredible event
here at the house it was a big moment
for the family Luke had not Lucas the
the younger of the of the two boys uh he
had not pooped in about a week and
yesterday David was taking a nap and
I've now found out that as new parents
you have to take a lot of naps to just
keep the whole operation going it's a
lot of naps David was taking a nap Luke
had not pooped in about a week now if
you're not a parent you may not know
that a child young child like this on
milk and everything they don't have to
poop every day people think they're just
pooping constantly but actually they
peel out of it out it's okay the doctor
said or the pediatrician said you know
if he doesn't
put you know like two weeks ten days we
got a problem we're rolling into like
day seven day eight
anyway yesterday David's taking a nap
I'm playing with the kids this child
freaking exploded
exploded I mean there was poop
everywhere and it was a substance that
cannot be it was sort of like the uh
like Venom you know from Spider-Man like
the black slime and you touch it and it
just and it kind of gets on you and
tries to like the Symbiote tries to it
was everywhere anyway point is uh he
pooped and then he slept the night first
first time ever he slept through the
night so it's a very exciting time
around here not only are we very excited
about that but this week ladles and
jelly spoons is the sixth year
anniversary of my famous or inFAMOUS why
I left the left video for prageru and uh
Brock mentioned to us uh Brock is our
social media Wizard and he mentioned to
us that you know this anniversary was
coming and maybe we should put together
a little something because you know my
political Evolution that you guys have
seen firsthand over these really it
started before six years ago but let's
say over these six years because it
really blew up from that why I left left
video moment
it's been so familiar to so many of you
guys that's why you watch the show and I
think it really is uh very connected to
what so many people in the country
people that have no idea who I am what
they're all going through like seeing
the excesses of the left trying to
figure out what the new political
landscape looks like and everything else
so subsequently I ended up doing three
more videos for Prager you I've done
I've done four of their four or five
minute videos and we thought why don't
we take all of those videos and put them
together add a little of my commentary
around them a little bit of video and
and sort of show the path that America
has been on for the last six years or so
uh so there was the why I left the left
video that was the first one uh then the
second one was so you think you're
tolerant the third one which coincided
with don't burn this book was The
Bravery deficit and my last one which
came out last year was three ways to fix
America anyway we will be releasing it
later today it's about a 25 minutes
something like that a video with
commentary in between and I think you're
going to find it really interesting and
hopefully hopefully helpful for those
moments when you're arguing arguing with
someone uh and you want to show them
something you know bite size and and
concise and clear I know 25 minutes
these days is an eternity but if you
want to show them something about where
the world was how things have changed
and how we can change accordingly or at
least learn let's say some better ideas
anyway here's just about a minute and a
half promo for that and then it will be
up first on locals this afternoon and
then we'll be everywhere later today
this month is the sixth year anniversary
of the famous or inFAMOUS why I left the
left video that I did for prageru you
may remember it might be hard for you to
remember but you might remember that I
once was a good Lefty I was a liberal I
was a Democrat all of those nice things
and then things started to change my
side the left was actually the ones that
were acting completely illiberately we
were the ones who were silencing free
speech on campus and shouting down
speakers we were focused on the
collective instead of the individual my
political Evolution was laid out in the
course of six years over four or five
minute videos but for me it wasn't just
about learning new ideas and being
unafraid to talk about them it was also
talking to people that I thought were my
ideological enemies whether they were
Dennis Prager or Glenn Beck or Larry
Elder or Jordan Peterson or Ben Shapiro
or the the list goes on I was willing to
talk to people hear what they had to say
and then compare that to my own thoughts
I think everything that I've spent the
last couple years talking about is
exactly what is needed in America right
now it's imperfect I'm imperfect you're
imperfect but if we fight for those
ideals and if we act a little bit more
bravely and we turn back to some of
those founding documents that sometimes
seem old and irrelevant I really think
we can fix this thing I'm Dave Rubin of
the Rubin report stealing these short
videos from prageru to shoot this film
whatever
there you go so that'll be up later
today I think you will dig it and now
let's get to Today's Show uh we're gonna
be doing a little bit of a destruction
of the left I know that's sort of common
to what we do around here uh but we're
gonna sort of take it at a personal
level a little bit of a fight has been
brewing between Bill Gates and Elon Musk
and it's sort of like one of those
Mortal Kombat choose your fighter or is
that which one was choose your fighter
that was Mortal Kombat or Street Fighter
I guess that Connor this is your
department choose your fighter that was
Mortal Kombat or Street Fighter you
don't know ah all right it was one of
those games but the point is we all have
to choose our fighter in this fight
because these are the the guys that uh
one way or another seem to be leading us
either to the promised land or a
horrifically dystopian future uh so
we'll talk a little bit about them then
we're going to connect some of this to
uh just a touch on the Grammys last
night I didn't watch the Grammys most
people didn't watch the Grammys it's
sort of like the Oscars and the Emmys at
this point people aren't really paying
attention to the Hollywood thing but a
certain subset of society still is and
it still wields influence so it's we're
at that like strange moment with so many
things in the mainstream do we just
ignore them do we just ignore all the
crap that Hollywood's putting out do we
ignore all the crap that CNN is pushing
on us do we ignore all the nonsense
that's happening at the New York Times
or do we have to push back to a certain
degree to expose it like I think there's
arguments on both sides of that but
we're going to be doing a little bit of
a pushback today and then yes we are
going to talk about this ridiculous uh
Chinese spy balloon that was flying over
the United States for days before we did
anything and we are going to expose some
hypocrisy to how the media covers
certain things when uh let's say Joe
Biden a Democrat is in office versus uh
perhaps a certain orange man and
Republicans and then just the usual cast
of characters that get out there for
this Administration and just say words
they love words and they have an
incredible ability to say word after
word afterward without saying anything
that is what they do all right here we
go so first let's start with Bill Gates
you guys know my feelings about Bill
Gates he is a globalist he is someone
who believes that because he created a
worthwhile product Microsoft and windows
and all that you know 40 some odd years
ago and he became a billionaire in the
process he somehow believes that he
should have dominion over your life when
it comes to where you should live and
what car you should drive and what you
should eat and all of those things he's
part of that Elite Intelligentsia that
if you just paid attention to them and
did what they want you'd own nothing and
be happy although he'll own an awful lot
of stuff and probably be significantly
happier in his very Twisted sense uh
anyway uh here is Bill Gates kind of uh
sticking it to Elon Musk talking about
in essence how good he is because he's
interested in helping people with
vaccines but you know Elon Musk he's
just wasting money that guy going to
Mars let's start Elon would you
encourage him to join your Club of Mega
philanthropists you Warren Buffett Jeff
Bezos people who give away most of their
work yeah I think someday he'll be a
great philanthropist obviously
you know things like Tesla having
positive impact uh even without being a
form of philanthropy but at the end of
the day I don't think he'll other than
going to Mars a few times uh which might
cost a little bit uh I don't think he'll
want to spend it on himself so yeah
someday I think he will uh join the rank
of of philanthropists using his
Ingenuity he's going to Mars whether
funded by him or others is that a good
use of money
uh not in my view but uh because there's
more pressing things to do on Earth
definitely and it's actually quite
expensive to go tomorrow have you looked
into it if you've got someone to do a
little break you know you can buy
measles vaccines and save lives for a
thousand dollars per life saved and so
it just kind of grounds you as in don't
go to don't go to Mars man there's a lot
there I was scribbling the entire time
um all right so first off this club of
Mega philanthropists I mean just because
you give money away it does not mean
that you are doing good with that money
when he's sort of given you know he's
poking and prodding Elon Musk there as
if only if you give your money away but
it's not just that you have to give it
away in a fashion that we want you to
give it in right if Elon was to put all
give away all of his money to to causes
that Bill Gates doesn't like then he
would not well first off he wouldn't be
allowed in that club I don't think Elon
Musk wants to be in that club you know
Elon Musk gets invited to Davos he gets
invited to the French Alps go go to all
of these things that these Mega
billionaires do and he does not he does
go to some of them he does not go to all
of them for sure and I don't think he
really wants to be in that club but the
point is that just giving away your
money in and of itself isn't good nor
bad it depends what the actual cause is
now I would argue that the causes that
Bill Gates uh would like Elon Musk to
give money for are probably not great
causes also there's something else here
that this this concept generally that
philanthropy must be good it must be
good because Bill Gates he has this
weird thing with success right he's
become really successful and he has a
ton of money and he has all of his
workers and his multiple houses and he's
the number one Farmland owner in the
United States and he keeps buying up
more and more property and all of those
things
um but Elon Musk what he's done is built
businesses that then create dreams for
people think of all the people that work
at let's say well SpaceX or Tesla SpaceX
is probably a better example think of
all the engineers all all of the
incredible scientists who have this
dream which is the most fundamental
thing there is as a human being to have
a dream and then try to accomplish that
dream through hard work and Ingenuity
and teamwork and all those things they
go they get that call that they got the
job
and now you're going to work at SpaceX
and you're maybe going to get us to Mars
that is the most affirming thing there
is as a human right like so Bill Gates
doesn't seem that interested in that he
doesn't think that that Adventure the
most Human Adventure every sci-fi movie
ever you know going to other planets
planets exploring the the final frontier
like he doesn't think that that's
interesting it's only good if you
somehow give your money to as he said
these thousand dollar measle vaccines
Bill Gates has billions and billions of
dollars now I understand he's given away
a lot and done a lot in research and
whatever and again we can put aside
whether you like him or not but right
now if if the thousand dollars per
measles shot is good why doesn't he give
another 20 million today Bill here's me
humble Dave Rubin calling on you today I
don't have that kind of cash man you
know but you do so please another 10
million it's nothing to you 10 million
is not even a half a percent of what
you've got listen to yourself give away
more money to stop the spread of measles
while while selfish Elon Musk takes us
to Mars and gives us electric cars and
tries to save free speech by buying a
failing product known as Twitter which
is just purging money but he did it
because he believes in free speech so so
Bill Gates there's just so many ways you
can hit him on this but but this the
dreams thing I think is the key part
that somehow you're only good I mean I
already said it you guys got it that
somehow you're already good you're only
good if you just give stuff away and
it's like no there are people who want
to accomplish awesome things and it
doesn't it that's not always directly
related to whether it's profitable here
or you can even see the reasons for it
in the immediacy but there is something
about this dream that humans need and I
would much rather follow somebody trying
to take us to Mars than follow somebody
who's trying to control cow farts and
that's exactly what Bill Gates is doing
here we go Australia's rare in that the
opportunity to succeed the things you
have to give up you have to give up a
large part of the and eventually almost
all of the coal mining activity uh you
know what happens with beef uh my
climate group breakthrough energy just
announced literally today an investment
in an Australian group called ruminate
that helps cows not be so much a source
of of methane emissions so we have two
paths to solving that that's six percent
of global emissions or cows uh who burp
and fart methane uh to an extreme degree
uh you can either fix the cows to stop
them doing that or you can make beef uh
without the cow and both of those you
know will be pursued to see which one
can lead to the best product in terms of
uh taste health and and cost and Bill
Gates just spews BS to an extreme degree
so you see what he's doing there Elon
Musk is doing the electric car thing
that's pretty good getting us to other
planets in case this thing really gets
out of control let's say these climate
people are right and the whole thing
isn't going to become inhibitable well
we've got to get going over there right
we better get going you'd think you'd be
into that no but he's focused on cow
farts he wants to stop coal none of
these things will affect his life in any
way but he really wants to control these
things and then he said you know
basically uh that they'll be going for
this fake meat too you know at the
height of covid one of my uh favorite
moments of being in La at the height of
covet and all of the craziness when I
had to go to the supermarket to just
stock up on whatever the hell you could
get remember they'd keep you outside you
had to go one at a time and Max and
people were wearing gloves and crazy
things over there whole bodies like all
of the lunacy I went to uh to the local
uh what was it uh not friends what was
the name of the store what was the what
was our Franks Ralph thank you I go to
Ralph's and it's that was like our main
Supermarket over there and basically the
shelves were completely empty Barren
like there was pretty much nothing left
except the beyond meat section was
jam-packed stocked because nobody people
would rather die of starvation watch
their children waste away to nothing
then eat those fake hamburgers and hot
dogs that Bill Gates wants you to be
consuming but the point of all of this
is that what Bill Gates is trying to do
here is show you Elon Musk is a bad guy
there are certain sets of people if they
don't join us in our climate Crusade we
just went through our covid Crusade and
now we've got a climate Crusade and
we've got to scare the hell everybody a
hell out of everybody and if you
disagree with our what I would say are
quasi-tyrannical solutions we are going
to label you all sorts of crazy things
now how do they do that labeling well
they do it through the media which
you're not going to believe this guys
but Bill Gates has basically bought and
paid for here is journalist I can
actually say journalist Matt taibi who
is one of the guys that released the
Twitter files on with Joe Rogan talking
about how much money Bill Gates has
pumped into media Outlets I mean again
the news business is so start for
Revenue
um that they'll they'll you know they'll
Bend to anybody basically did you see
that I mean I know Jimmy Dore covered it
but quite a few other people have
realized it now the amount of money the
that Bill Gates has spent on influencing
media no I I I did somewhere in the
neighborhood of 300 million dollars jeez
recently examined nearly 20 000
charitable grants The Gates Foundation
made through the end of June and found
that more than 250 million going towards
journalism receipts included news
operations like the BBC NBC Al Jazeera
propublica National journey of the
Guardian Univision medium the financial
times the Atlantic Texas Tribune Gannett
Washington monthly lamond Lamont is that
I say it yeah and uh the center for
investigative reporting and as a
reporter you may not may or may not be
aware of all the different ways that
money will get in you know work its way
into the business but unconsciously it
just sort of seeps in like right and
that's how it works like you nobody
comes and tells you well don't cover
this
um well maybe they do now actually uh or
or you know take this approach to
covering education you what what ends up
happening is you just kind of get a feel
based on the reaction of your Editor to
whatever pitch uh you're giving at the
moment
I think taibi's last point there is the
interesting one when Gates gives this
money so 250 million dollars to those
organizations I mean you heard the list
there like they're basically all leftist
organizations and then they just so
happen to be in line with all of gates
feelings about climate change and the
world economic forum and everything else
you know that is in stark contrast
ladies and gentlemen to the way we do
the Reuben report here you know we do it
we're fan funded that's it I don't get
money from anybody else and nobody that
does fund us on locals has any control
over my content I don't even know what
everyone who's watching this political
beliefs are and that's just fine right
if I started taking money I mean really
just try to think about this for a
second if Bill Gates called us up and
said hey Dave you know you've been a
little critically a little critical of
me lately but I can tell you're a decent
guy and I'm a decent guy so we'd like to
give you five hundred thousand dollars a
year for a couple years and you just
keep doing the show to the best of your
ability do you think I might be less
critical of Bill Gates then so do you
see how this thing operates it's not
that they sit them down that's how you'd
be saying although maybe they do now
because it's become so Brazen but this
is what they do and this is what we have
seen
pharmaceutical companies and virtually
every big machine entity do they buy
everything we often have shown you that
video that compilation video of the news
shows on NBC ABC CBS CNN et cetera where
they all cut to commercial brought to
you by Pfizer
well last night was the Grammys and
you're not going to believe who the
Grammys were brought to you by
[Applause]
[Music]
think of the Brazen Ridiculousness of
Pfizer
there is no everyone knows Pfizer at
this point I would think that a huge
amount of people don't like Pfizer but
the idea that Pfizer would put their
money into the Grammys so that they
could get more of their commercials out
there more of their messaging at this
juncture when we know that the vaccines
are not working as they were told us
they were going to work I know two
people with covet right now both are
vaxed and boosted right like it's just
this whole thing is just complete
nonsense utter nonsense but maybe that's
part of it that they keep pushing it on
us so that the more that you see how
ridiculous it is the more they have to
push it on us because that's all that's
left for these people here's a video
that I saw this is wild this is a
commercial this is a Pfizer commercial
that debuted a couple days ago you're
going to see a whole bunch of
celebrities and athletes and blah blah
blah in it and uh just look at they just
keep coming it just does not stop
If This Were the real covid-19 I would
be in real trouble because I have asthma
and I have depression
I have diabetes
and I struggle with my weight for us
covet is a whole different ballgame
in fact you could be one of almost 200
million Americans with a high risk
factor that makes covid even riskier
which is why you need to be ready and
have a plan other risk factors including
heart disease or being inactive
even being over 50 or being a smoker can
put you with serious risk
could that be you find out go to
noplango.com and know your risk factors
then make a plan
coveted on top
like I did the last thing you want to do
is wait and see be ready have a plan
and ask your doctor about treatment
options that may help
first off how about you freaks work out
don't smoke take a walk there is this
giant glowing thing in the sky that
provides light and warmth thus when the
light and warmth when the Rays hit you
it creates vitamin D in your body and
then that starts making you feel good I
can tell you it's true here in Florida
it really is I would love to know how
much Michael Phelps and Jean Smart and
who else was in that video what a
collection of quest love whoever that is
uh and pink how much they got paid for
that but the point is they keep coming
at us with these things also can someone
explain to me now I get it pink has
asthma now I will accept
that if you have asthma and you get
covid that there's a complication there
because of the lung situation I think
that's a decreasing uh issue because the
the recent variants of Kobe don't seem
to be affecting people's lungs but let's
just put that aside for a second I will
accept asthma then I guess the the guy
with that was Questlove the guy who said
he was fat he didn't look that fat to me
I don't know who Quest love is but I
will also accept that if you're if
you're fat I guess covet has a little
more of an issue which also was
connected to the diabetes one that I
think Gene Smart said but again this is
how about get outside how about ride a
bike how about take a walk how about
sweat some of these things play tennis
just like get out there inducing the one
that I'm a little confused about Michael
Phelps has depression
how did depression become a like a
comorbidity for covet just because like
I'm depressed in that way if covet I'm
double depressed well then there's some
other depression pill for that I don't
think there's a coveted pill you have to
take it's just it's just nonsense like
I'm sure they can figure it out some way
if you're depressed that means your
immune system is depressed
these people but but the point is
they're just not gonna stop and you know
why not they're not going to stop
because they are driven by Satan
by Satan himself here's Sam Smith who I
guess was a dude now he's half a dude or
he's part chick or he's something right
anyway he was at uh the Grammys last
night with Kim Petrus I don't know who
she is but they had this whole Satan
song and we thought we'd play a little
clip
[Music]
here we go
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
I don't know what that was again I
didn't watch these things I'm only
seeing them but I and this is one of
those things okay so do you amplify
these things by talking about them like
to expose the dribble look I'm not some
like Puritan like sitting here like oh
my God art is evil and blah blah blah
you know like in the 80s you know we had
mega death and we had who is the the guy
that was a girl back in the 80s uh not
David Bowie the one with the snakes and
all that thing you're like the point is
the art artists do all kinds of things
but while this is being brought to you
by Pfizer and the worship of Satan and
just like all the weird things it's just
like is Hollywood just unable to stop
for a second and be like let's think
about what we're doing here what message
Sam Smith was a man now he's a woman and
like what message are we putting out to
the people here also the music is not
good
I am told Connor just told me that that
song Whatever It Is is played at the
Miami uh Beach like at the clubs all
night long I didn't know you were in the
scene man yeah oh you walk past them you
walk past him as you're going to
Chipotle late night you badass
um I I don't go to the club you know
what later today not while I'm doing
this live stream put Frank Sinatra in
your Google search thing in your YouTube
thing listen to any Frank Sinatra song
and then try to listen to that crap
these are not I I don't know
like music is wide people have different
tastes but like there's good music out
there try some of that see how you feel
Frank Sinatra was not a devil worshiper
as far as I know those are the days
anyway here's Harry Styles and like some
sort of half dress half like just look
at it what an embarrassment these people
are
[Music]
[Applause]
yes I do have something similar to that
but I don't wear it out that's private
nobody wants to wear that Harry Styles
does not want to wear that the the list
I could have shown you at Twitter
somebody did a Twitter thread of these
freaks with these crazy clothing just
put on normal clothes and get out there
and make your music it's okay but they
cannot stop that's the point of all this
whether it's Bill Gates or Harry Styles
or brought to you by Pfizer execs all of
these people they are just on the slow
road to hell and nobody can stop them
there is an entropy to it that cannot be
stopped now this is just spectacular uh
spectacularly horrible actually uh so
Disney has you know and you know Disney
they used to do uh you know Mickey Mouse
and Donald Duck whatever happened to
Donald Duck bring that guy back
that would be good but no they can't do
that what do they have to do they have
to turn children into little racist
ahistorical Maniacs so one of the women
you remember from a few months ago when
we showed you that leaked Zoom call
where the former CEO of Disney he has
since been fired Bob chapek was on with
the diversity Equity inclusion group and
they were all talking about their trans
kids and how they secretly put gay
messaging into people into their movies
and all of this stuff anyway that guy
got fired one of the women who was on
that panel she has a new show she's an
executive producer she's got a new show
out on Disney kids and tell me if this
is just good old-fashioned child
programming or perhaps something a
little more nefarious designed to break
your children's brains enjoy
oh
this country was built on slavery which
means slaves built this country till
this land from sea to Sea to Sea first
there was rice tobacco sugarcane see
when they did his thing
can and we weren't soldiers four million
strong fighting for America's freedoms
even though we remained America slave
built this country this
and we the descendants of slaves in
America have earned reparations for
their suffering and continue to earn
reparations every moment we spend
submerged in the systemic Prejudice
racism and white supremacy that America
was founded with and still has not atone
form slaves built this country not only
filled hands but Carpenters Masons
blacksmiths musicians
[Music]
and women
emancipation is not freedom
did you catch that at the end why are
they sticking it to Abraham Lincoln
Abraham Lincoln freed the slaves Abraham
Lincoln basically started a political
party because he was not happy with what
was going on with slavery uh he saved
the freaking Union maybe that wasn't the
best idea in retrospect but boy at the
end like this Iran Abraham Lincoln
there's such nonsense in there but
putting aside all of the nonsense and
how they're actually making a political
agenda you might look you can talk in a
cartoon you can actually teach kids a
lot of things almost everything I
learned I learned from Bugs Bunny and
Looney Tunes right but but to to push
such a specific policy agenda too that
what we have to do really kids kids I
mean who's watching this so imagine a
five-year-old watching that you're gonna
get this very distorted view of what
history was and then Mommy I want
reparations like what what is wrong with
these people but you should not be
surprised because the ex the executive
producer of that trash that propaganda
trash that most likely some of you still
are paying for Disney plus you're paying
for it I don't have it anymore her name
is Latoya ravenue and uh you may
remember her because she's got her gay
agenda for the kids which of course is
directly related to the Black Agenda
because as you know queer Theory and
black history are like two peas in a pot
you know Proud Family Disney TVA
um the showrunners were super welcoming
Meredith Roberts and like the our
leadership over there has been so
welcoming to like my like not at all
secret gay agenda and so like I I feel
like I felt like it was I mean like
maybe it was that way in the past but I
guess like something must have happened
in the last like like they were turning
it around they're going hard and then
all that like momentum that I felt like
that
sense of I don't have to be afraid to
like let's have these two characters
Kiss let's in the background like I was
just wherever I could just basically
adding queerness to like if you see
anything queer in the show I'm proud of
them but like I just was like no one
would stop me and no one was trying this
all right this woman
uh she identifies we did a little
research on this this is true I'd never
heard this one she identifies as
biromantic asexual which sounds a little
self-conflicting uh but uh we did a
little research here by romantic people
can be romantically attracted to people
of two or more genders
in other words multiple genders she is
bi-romantic how is that different than
bisexual like what what
oh because you're not sexually attracted
this is all happening on the Fly people
by romantic people so that means you're
you're out with the dude and the chick
they're sitting across the table you're
looking at both of them going I am
emotionally attached to both of you
frankly don't want to bang either one of
you sounds like you have some other
problem and I'm pretty sure nobody wants
to bang some buy romance oh God it's
awful
anyway you may remember also that in
that original Zoom call on the Disney
thing there was that other woman who
said that she had what did she have she
had a trans daughter and a and an
asexual son or a
pansexual son which as Jordan Peterson
pointed out is almost mathematically
impossible you know what I mean like you
have a daughter who suffers from gender
dysphoria and a son who has no sexuality
whatsoever and you happen to work in a
corporation at a corporation at the very
division that is designed to up
everyone's brains this is wild people
anyway all of this is connected all of
it's connected it really really is uh
and the lunacy so much of it is coming
from one of the political parties in
Washington DC right now and that happens
to be the Democrats and the Democrats as
you know last week all went completely
bananas because Kevin McCarthy who's the
new leader of the house did exactly what
he said he was going to do he was going
to remove Adam's ship he was going to
remove Eric swalwell
and he was going to remove ilhan Omar
from uh some some security clearance and
on some committees that they're on
basically the the house a foreign
affairs committee okay now Eric swalwell
has slept with the Chinese spy everyone
knows it uh Adam Schiff basically made
up Russia collusion and then wasted
millions and millions of taxpayers
dollars and people's attention and time
on all this Russian nonsense ilhan Omar
some people did something on 9 11 like
she is a bad bad woman uh anyway here
she is because what do Democrats do you
get fired and by the way nobody is
supposed nobody is given the right to be
on the Foreign Affairs Community uh
committee when a new party takes over
they can put their own people on just
like the Democrats did by putting ilhan
Omar and Adam Schiff and Eric swallow on
so this is politics you get in you have
power you put more of your people in
positions of power this is politics 101
but now that McCarthy has removed these
three uh they are of course all playing
the victim but but ilhan are by far the
biggest victim and then of course when
you're a Democrat you're a victim you
get to go on corporate television and
talk about your victimhood
we know what this is this is about this
is about saying this particular member
of Congress
is not allowed to have a voice on the
Foreign Affairs committee this
particular member of of Congress is
someone that we don't think is
appropriate in voicing and that comes
back to the fact that they don't
actually think Muslims
or you know refugees or immigrants in
this country can appropriately criticize
U.S policy can appropriately criticize
you know policies of of other countries
man she is such she's such a lying
little snake that's all she is no one no
one on the Republican side is has a
problem with Muslims or black people or
anything else are there individual races
in society yes which that is not why she
is being removed she is being removed
partly at least because look do I run
around on this show and run around and
call people racists and bigots and
anti-semites and all those things
unjustly obviously not you it's the last
move you want to make you only want to
use those labels when they are actually
specifically appropriate her obsessive
focused hatred of Israel this tiny
little country right with six million
people uh that she is obsessed with the
only Western democracy that would let a
woman like her rail against it all day
long uh that is what she is obsessed
with that might have a little something
to do with some Jews living there so she
obviously is an anti-semite obviously
right
the Democrats can choose to hang out
with her or not and it's fine they all
defended her so be it
um but McCarthy does not owe her a place
on a committee it is as simple as that
right this is not because she's black or
whatever she is and it's not because
she's Muslim and it's not because she's
a woman and it's not because she's an
immigrant or anything else ugh she is
gross and speaking of gross here's
Rashida to lead
censor congresswoman Omar in the same
week they introduced a bill to ban
federal employees from engaging in
censorship
where are
the Free Speech Warriors today
has expired that our country is failing
you today through this Chambers the
gentleman is no longer recognized well
shut up just like the crocodile tears
another disgusting one to leave they're
just terrible and no one's being
censored Talib can go on every MSNBC
crazy show and say whatever she wants
ilhan Omar can do the same thing they
can say whatever they want in Congress
and bring up whatever bills they want
and expose themselves as the racist
little monsters that they are they can
do all of those things you don't have a
right to be on a committee right if all
they did they removed three people right
so again they removed swallow white guy
they removed Schiff white guy and ilhan
Omar so was this all about race and
bigotry and hating women and everything
else anyway uh you may have seen a whole
bunch of these type of hysterical videos
that were all out on Friday where the
Democrats one at a time more hysterical
than the next and crying and screaming
and genuflecting and just absolute
Ridiculousness this was my favorite one
this was AOC
ardos
and yeah
we're doing God's work here guys we
really are uh here's AOC accusing
Republicans of terrorism
both of us were in alignment on did you
feel safe sitting there with him
I think it's uncomfortable
um serving with people who engage in
what many experts deem stochastic
terrorism which is the incitement of
violence in a uh which is an incitement
of violence using digital means and
large platforms so that individual
themselves may not be the one that's
wielding a weapon but I have had to ride
as a as has representative Omar have had
consistently had to ride in 20 000 pound
armored vehicles in um in you know
engaging in some of the most gruesome
threats that you can imagine that were
incited by Republican members this is
not just about a tweet it is about what
life looks like and and the
and the marshalling of hundreds
thousands if not millions of people
um into doing something and Donald Trump
knows that very well and he uses and
used his rallies very strategically in
order to engage in political
intimidation of what he deemed his
political enemies guys I really mean
this clearly do not fall for this
from these people anymore if
she's concerned about stoactic terrorism
uh then she should be concerned stoactic
is that what it's called stoactic
terrorism stochastic terrorism I think
it's stochastic so Aztec doesn't even
matter the point is that this woman
always wants to play the victim somehow
there are millions now of people out
trying to get her this is the same woman
who calls the half the country white
supremacist all the time calls her
colleagues white supremacists and bigots
and Nazi adjacent or whatever it else
she does so is she doing that same exact
Scholastic is that the word Scholastic
is she doing the Scholastic terrorism
them herself if right because she's not
saying go kill those people but in
essence she's saying they're trying to
kill me so you got you better do
something just absolutely terrible do
not fall for their guilt-ridden drivel
any more and and of course it is always
propagated by the mainstream media but
Republicans are getting balls and I've
been saying this for weeks and I'm
really impressed with what's going on
right now Kevin McCarthy after that you
know five-day fight uh with you know
certain members of his own party I think
he has come in and he's showing attitude
and they're making changes listen to
this exchange between Kevin McCarthy and
a member of the media a journalist uh
while talking about ilhan Omar
um I just want to get you to comment on
some of the things that uh leader
Jeffrey said he had a press conference
before you he had these posters up of
some of the words that members of your
conference have said in the past so can
you just respond to some Democrats who I
was I wasn't at the press conference so
can you tell me an example I'm just
saying he for example yeah comments from
Marjorie Taylor green is she on Foreign
Affairs no no I was she on Intel okay I
make my case
that's the point nobody was silenced
Marjorie Taylor Green's not on these
things and ilhan Omar is no longer on
these things they are both in Congress
and it's okay so keep going Kevin
McCarthy do not fall for the bait the
bait but also you guys watching these
things when your friends are like you
know I saw an iOS on CNN AOC said that
she's suffering from stochastic Terror
terrorism stochastic one more time
stochastic she's got stochastic
terrorism coming for her and it's like
no what she's doing is the exact same
thing by the way when she's in those
armored cars uh and she has you know
what she has you know it's always
running right on the side of Armored
Cars you're not gonna believe this armed
men so she also wants to take your guns
away but she's gonna have plenty of
people with guns around her but speaking
of intelligence and Foreign Affairs
because Foreign Affairs are important
and I would say on the Foreign Affairs
committee where you're going to be
getting classified information about
about threats and foreign governments
and all sorts of things I would want
people who I would say are roughly
pro-america I would say ilhan Omar would
love for the destruction of America that
is fairly obvious she is incapable of
saying anything positive about America
she's for Equity instead of equality
she's destroyed Minneapolis
people keep voting her in that's up to
them so be it but
with intelligence in mind the big story
of the weekend is that a Chinese spy
balloon has been flying over America for
days it was finally shot down but for
days it collected information over
America and we just let it happen here's
a little video of its final moment
checking Twitter on several different
officials up
I believe it just happened there
that was it live raw and unfiltered it
appears that that China spy balloon
I've run unfiltered it appears that that
Chinese Supply balloon has been shot
down after days of getting information
and transmitting it back to the
motherland so we let this thing just fly
over the country taking pictures video
we don't even know what it was doing
necessarily we don't know if it was
sending it Communications back we just
have no idea people are saying this
could be a trial for an EMP device like
there's all sorts of crazy stuff related
to this but generally uh as a superpower
or as any Sovereign Nation if another
country flies some weird into your
airspace you don't let it happen because
if you let it happen once you know
they're going to do it again you don't
know exactly what they're going for in
terms of the information and everything
else and it just shows weakness so we
did not do it for days but then
yesterday Joe Biden said that he
actually did want it shot down and
basically got overridden from your was
from your nationality I told them to
shoot it down oh Wednesday on Wednesday
but the recommendation they said to me
let's wait till the safest place to do
it what does this mean person
it's interesting I I actually respect
the president
for listening to his military advisors
like you don't want somebody just going
in shoot it down I don't I don't need to
know anything I don't know what it's
still I don't need to know what it's
doing or where it's going or so okay
it's interesting I suppose that he
waited and listened to his guys right
now again we don't know all the
information related all this but it was
also interesting the way he said maybe
we could throw back through it the way
he said I said shoot it down the
implication being I do what I want
they're the ones to blame for this
nonsense
from your was from your National I told
them to shoot it down oh Wednesday on
Wednesday like the recommendation they
said to me let's wait till the safest
place to do it what does this mean
Persona revelation of China
all right short and sweet as I said we
don't have all the information as to
what exactly this thing was doing but
the point is if he said shoot it down on
Wednesday and then for days and days it
continued to collect information it
didn't get shot down until yesterday uh
you have to wonder what information was
passed to the Chinese what test did they
just do to us and did we pass that test
and it doesn't even sound like Biden was
in agreement with his guys again you
want to take advice from these guys make
a decision that's why his tone there but
I get it he is dementia so his tone is
often disregulated
um now Mark uh Mark Miley is the guy
that said don't shoot it down we should
wait for a little bit and it made us
think well well what is general Miley
what has he been up to uh is he is he
dealing with the important issues of the
day or could it be something else you
may remember this one and it is
important that we train and we
understand uh and I want to understand
white rage and I'm white and I want to
understand it well hopefully uh the
Chinese spy balloon was looking into
white rage and then he can get some
information on the Chinese about white
rage and he is white so it's something
that he's interested in I mean the point
is once you allow this Equity nonsense
this woke BS once you allow it into the
system like think if if the United
States government has spent one second
thinking about white rage inequity and
we know that they have it figuring out
what bathrooms female soldiers should go
to at Fort Bragg and elsewhere and all
this stuff it's like you're taking your
eye off the ball that's why the woke
thing is so dangerous anything whether
it's the military the government whether
it's a shoe company
or quite literate or a production
company once you let wokism into the
system you have a mission right your
mission is to build a good product your
mission is to get the correct
information out there your mission might
just be literally to make money and
that's it but once you let the woke
thing in you are taking your eye off the
ball you are you are in dereliction of
your duty I'm fairly certain that the
joint Chief staff chairman his job is
not to look into white rage but that's
what they're doing but it's not just him
it's everyone associated with this
Administration is a sham and a clown and
a ridiculous buffoon we've got plenty of
clips of gay Pete to show you right now
here is gay pedar Transportation
secretary who only got hired because
he's gay as you know he was the mayor of
a small town South Bend Indiana has no
qualifications to be in charge of
Transportation literally none whatsoever
but he cut a deal with Biden to get out
of the race and he's gay so you know
it's spectacular here he is with uh
Democrat activist Jake Tapper on CNN uh
talking about the balloon
the military gauge the different risks
and the different benefits of different
approaches made the decisions that they
did brought this thing down with that
incident right but the presumption has
got to be that the Chinese were able to
gather intelligence hovering over the
United States for day after day
especially over some of these sensitive
sites I'm sure there's a similar
presumption about what Spy satellites do
that is well outside of my Lane I'm just
glad that nobody was hurt as this thing
came down I don't know I don't even know
why
that's out of my way I mean look it's so
ridiculous these people so this thing
was flying over military sites we have
no in no idea what information pictures
video audio we have simply no idea where
they were they looking at critical
infrastructure we have no idea but then
they send bootage out there to talk
about something that he admits he has no
idea what he's supposed to be talking
about but he continued he was all over
the news this weekend Not only was he
with Democrat activist Jake Tapper he
was also with super Democrat activist
Chuck Todd but Chuck Todd every now and
again tries to ask a question that seems
somewhat relevant so that he doesn't
seem like a total partisan act he's not
particularly good at it here he is
asking Pete about the classified
document scandal
he had been more transparent about this
classified document situation earlier
that he might be in a better place
better place Coulda Woulda Shoulda is
not the Strategic direction or focus of
this Administration there's too much on
the line there's too much to do there's
too much to do people do you know how
much more they can ruin if we give
them enough time so he goes on Tapper
says he can't really give an answer
about the satellite then he goes on
Chuck Todd he can't really comment on uh
Biden and the classified documents and
they just keep putting him out there
here's more uh with Chuck Todd Chuck
asked him about Biden's approval numbers
which are not good
he's got a lot of things to tell
why do you think that it has not
penetrated the American public well
these things don't sell themselves and
it's one of the reasons I'm really
looking forward to that that State of
the Union Address I will say that there
have been so many accomplishments under
this Administration it can be difficult
to list them in a distilled way
Pete you could have done it right then
and there but instead they just say
meaningless platitudes they've done so
much guys so much guys we've given a
hundred million dollars no 100 billion
it's 100 billion 100 million that's
chump change we've given 100 billion
dollars with no receipts to Ukraine
that's something we've done
um we did have the most embarrassing
withdrawal of a country ever in
Afghanistan that's something we did we
destroyed the supply chain uh you forced
all sorts of people to inject themselves
with poison the list guys we just
haven't had a chance to distill it it's
also hilarious when they say this
because these people go on the shows to
get sucked off did you listen to the way
that Chuck Todd even laid out that
question the president's got an awful
lot to be proud of in essence you're
right like the president's got so much
good stuff and then Pete can't even come
up with that the list is just too long
to tell you Chuck that's a little bit
different than we showed you that video
last week was it Chuck Todd and Jim
Jordan was it Jim Jordan and then and
they're in this battle this battle
because Chuck Todd is a Democrat
activist but they have to keep the game
going in some weird way because too many
of us are seeing behind the curtain so
every now and again they have to ask
somewhat of a critical question so it
doesn't seem like their total partisan
hacks here's Chuck Todd acknowledging
that most people two-thirds of us
actually are just not interested in what
Joe Biden selling when President Biden
addresses the nation on Tuesday night he
will be speaking to a skeptical public
despite the low unemployment rate a
stronger than expected midterm
performance for his political party and
a string of legislative accomplishments
the president's job rating sits at just
45 percent his poll numbers are even
lower on his handling of the economy
foreign policy and specifically the war
in Ukraine two-thirds of Voters have
reservations who are very uncomfortable
with the idea of Biden running for a
second term yeah two-thirds of people I
guess don't have brain damage that seems
a little high to me frankly uh but an
increasing amount of people are going
okay the guy's not cognitively fit
Chinese spy disastrous with withdrawal
of Afghanistan what's going on with the
economy we're pissed about the Jabs
nobody got fired over anything like all
of the stuff so every now and again the
corporate media has to and in some ways
what they're doing even when they when
they criticize them is carrying order
because they want to get the base riled
up to make sure that the base comes out
and votes but what's this all really
about what it really obviously is all
about is that nobody no it's just true
guys it's just true nobody in their
right mind show me somebody I've tweeted
this out before and it's and it's gotten
huge traction and I can't get anyone to
to defend Biden like who are the real
supporters of this Administration
besides like the globalists and the
corporatists and the journalist class
where are the average people that are
like yes Joe Biden is fit to be
president he's the one that have should
have his finger on the button and he's
making sense and these policies make
sense nobody there's nobody that
supports any of this nonsense so what
they're really afraid of is that a
little sanity could bring the
Republicans some major wins it could get
this country back on track and I think
that's the direction that we're heading
I think I pray that's the direction
we're heading and you have to have open
yet and and there are reasons to believe
that one of the reasons to believe that
is the way the machine keeps coming
after Ron DeSantis Florida as you know
in case you haven't heard me talk about
it is absolutely flourishing we are
cutting to the minimal taxes that we
have we don't even have an income tax
here but we're cutting taxes left and
right we are rebuilding at the after the
hurricane at incredible levels uh the
economy is flourishing here the one
issue that we do have is that house
prices are high because basically 1200
people a day move here to enjoy the
freedom and it is hard to build even
faster but the Santa's is cutting as
much regulation even on that everything
is going good here people smile at you
here that's nice I was in Cali last week
not a lot of smiling anyway listen to
the way oh God this woman do we have a
can we show something do we have
something here we can warn the people
about
okay good we like to put the warnings I
don't want to freak you guys out we're
going to Joy Reed over at the televised
mental institution MSNBC and listen to
the way she talks about DeSantis and
Florida it's incredible this is It's
just incredible what the Santa is doing
is intentional in order to peel off
Trump's Republican voters and get them
on his side ahead of his presidential
bid in 2024. he's turning Florida into a
right-wing Paradise where the focus
isn't on health care or jobs or taxes or
infrastructure I don't know hurricane or
flood insurance in one of the most
natural disaster prone states in the
country you know normal Governor stuff
but rather on the right-wing culture
wars and nothing but the right-wing
culture wars and he's ticking all the
boxes not only is he Banning books about
history and any mention of the existence
of gay people from Florida schools he's
barring public high schools from
teaching AP African-American studies
he's taking aim at drag performances
even suggesting that he would urge the
state's Child Protective Services to
investigate parents who take their own
kids to one
he's actively trying to ban coveted
vaccine mandates and restricting Mass
rules while at the same time calling for
probes into supposed wrongdoing linked
to the vaccine and he's doing all of
this or making sure that anyone can walk
around with a gun no permit required
it's a right-wing Fantasy Land like
Disney World but in Hell come to Florida
the meanest place on Earth
I want to be very clear about this
please don't come here I know you'll end
up vacationing here the next time they
lock you down wherever you live I don't
know where you live I don't care where
you live but please don't come here we
don't want you here we don't want people
like you here and joy that has nothing
to do with your skin color I have no
doubt that Media Matters is watching
this right now going Dave Rubin doesn't
want black people in Florida
you people are all complete clowns
everything she said right there was a
distortion of the truth first off he's
not doing anything on taxes he's cutting
taxes we'll get to that in just a second
he's not doing anything on
infrastructure do you know how fast we
rebuilt the Pine Island Bridge and the
Sanibel Causeway it was incredible it
would have taken two years to rebuild
that Sanibel Causeway they did it in two
weeks here we are redoing look I would
welcome anyone to visit me come visit
Dave Rubin and see what's going on in
his neighborhood where our roads are
being rebuilt they're they're absolutely
beautiful everywhere you go it's
happening constantly where there's no
crime here at Miami which is the biggest
city uh you know the biggest
Metropolitan city in Florida where where
it is the safest city in the United
States right now it's incredible
absolutely incredible I told you guys
last week we're in the middle of the
show and I'm talking about how horrible
San Francisco is with the homelessness
and the crime and the drugs and all that
the mayor freaking texted me in the
middle of the show he said Dave I'm
watching you right now just FYI we only
have 640 homeless people here in Miami
and we're doing everything we can to
reduce that that's the difference
between in a functioning place but if
this is what a right wing dream is then
hello it's pretty freaking spectacular
but since Joy is concerned about what
Ron DeSantis is doing here he's not
doing anything for the people and
usually what they mean is you're not
doing anything for the children for the
children remember Nancy Pelosi why is
she running against other children well
here's what DeSantis is doing we're also
doing permanent sales tax exclusions on
all baby Necessities including cribs and
strollers it's hard enough raising kids
as it is now you get baby food diapers
wipes the whole baby clothes the whole
shebang including things like cribs and
stores which are very very expensive so
that is going to be permanently tax-free
in the State of Florida yeah that's what
we're doing here right we're actually
strengthening the family here I know
that's crazy and antithetical to
everything you believe you bananas Lefty
lunatic Joy Reed also of course what she
said about that you can't say gay here
is nonsense and they are not Banning
books here they're actually Banning
books in California here they don't want
that the book what Was a gender child or
queer Theory child or whatever they
don't want kids five-year-olds getting
books about how to give a hand job call
me old school I'm down with that you
know what I mean like these people are
completely utterly ridiculous he did not
ban African-American studies he banned a
course that was going to teach critical
race Theory and gender queer Theory
within the lens of black history and
reparations that's what he banned that
is not in education that is
indoctrination all of this stuff you get
it and what they also fear is that the
first lady here in Florida gets it too
and and they're they're a tag team Duo
uh that really is just doing what we're
all asking for think some of those
Federal bureaucracies can take a page
from the DeSantis Playbook and learn how
to get things done quickly efficiently
effectively cut the red tape
and let's just work on behalf of people
in need yeah and that's exactly what
Casey DeSantis is doing by the way who
led all of the fundraising uh for uh
post hurricaneian and the destruction in
Southwest Florida and then we raise
millions and uh FEMA cut their aid
Florida which has a budget surplus
despite no state income tax is covering
the rest and I think you guys get the
point of all of this that ladies and
gentlemen is our Monday show 59 minutes
and 33 seconds we're going to make it to
a cool 60 Minutes one hour on the dot uh
we're gonna go do a post-game show for
locals members exclusively and then the
prageru doc that I mentioned before
which is a compilation of all four of my
prageru videos with some ins and outs
and b-roll and video that explains a
little bit of how the country changed as
I changed and how that Evolution was uh
really just it was it was alongside of
you guys that'll be up first on locals
today and then later this evening on
Rumble and YouTube and everywhere else
60 minutes see you tomorrow
[Music]